♫
>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT THE
EXCLUSIVE INVESTIGATION WE
SHOWED YOU TWO PAT TESTS
THAT GOOGLE HAS FILED FOR.
THEY SHOW THE COMPANY’S
WILLINGNESS TO STICK A
CAMERA IN YOUR BEDROOM TO
SPY ON YOU AND YOUR CHILDREN
AND USE THE INFORMATION TO
SELL YOU THINGS.
APPARENTLY GOOGLE DOESN’T
HAVE CAMERA IN EVERY BEDROOM
OR EVERY HOME.
IT DOES HAVE A PHONE IN
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE’S POCKETS
THOUGH.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
INFORMATION IS GOOGLE
GETTING FROM THOSE PHONES?
WE PUT A COUPLE OF OUR
SMARTEST PRODUCERS ON THIS
AND WE SENT FOX NEWS
HEADLINES ANCHOR BRET LARSON
OUT TO INVESTIGATE.
WATCH.
>> WE KNOW THAT GOOGLE IS
TRACKING US.
WE AGREE TO IT WHEN WE SET
UP OUR PHONES.
SO WE WANTED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT EXACTLY GOOGLE IS
LEARNING ABOUT US THROUGHOUT
THE DAY.
SO HERE’S WHAT WE’RE GOING
TO DO.
WE HAVE TWO IDENTICAL
PHONES.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THESE TWO PHONES IS THIS ONE
IS IN AIRPLANE MODE.
BOTH OF THE PHONES LACK A
SIM CARD AND HAVEN’T BEEN
SET UP TO ACCESS ANY WI-FI
NETWORKS OF FOR ALL INTENTS
AND PURPOSES THEY HAVE NO
CONNECTION TO A DATA
NETWORK.
KEEP THEM WITH US THROUGHOUT
THE DAY.
WHEN I TRAVEL AROUND D.C.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT GOOGLE
IS FINDING OUT ABOUT ME.
OUR FIRST STOP SIMS
CONVENIENCE STORE OUTSIDE
THE FOX BUREAU FOR QUICK
COFFEE.
TOOK A WALK TO THE CAPITOL
AND TOOK A QUICK WALK AROUND
THE SENATE OFFICE BUILDING
AND DECIDED TO HOP IN A CAR
AND HEAD AROUND TOWN.
HELLO.
>> HOW ARE YOU.
>> GOING TO THE CHILDREN’S
HOSPITAL, PLEASE.
>> TO RUN OUR TEST, WHEN WE
TO DO MORE THAN WALK THE
BLOCK.
SO WE TOOK A TOUR AROUND OUR
NATION’S CAPITOL.
FIRST DUE NORTH TO THE
CHILDREN’S NATIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER HOSPITAL AND WEST TO
SAINT AL BAN’S SCHOOL AND
THE NATIONAL CATHEDRAL.
OUR TOUR AROUND TOWN WAS A
14-MILE JOURNEY THAT LASTED
MORE THAN AN HOUR.
THE ENTIRE TIME THE PHONES
HAD NO ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
NOT A WI-FI CONNECTION AND
NOT ANY CELLULAR DATA
SERVICE.
IT ALMOST SEEMED QUAINT TO
ASSUME THAT GOOGLE WOULDN’T
EVEN BE ABLE TO COLLECT DATA
ON ME.
>> HEAD BACK TO THE BUREAU,
MY FRIEND.
THAT CHURCH IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> GOOGLE’S BUSINESS MODEL
IS SIMPLE.
COLLECT DATA ON ITS USERS
AND USE THAT DATA TO SELL
TARGETED ADS.
IT’S A BUSINESS MODEL CALLED
SURVEILLANCE CAPITALISM.
DOES THAT CRITICAL DATA
COLLECTION WORK EVEN WHEN
YOUR PHONES AREN’T
CONNECTED?
SO WE’RE BACK HERE AT OUR
FOX BUREAU IN D.C.
AND WE HAVE GOT BOTH OF OUR
PHONES EXACTLY HOW WE LEFT
WITH THEM.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE, REALLY,
I SNAPPED A COUPLE OF BAD
SHELFIES AT THE NATIONAL
CATHEDRAL:  BUT OTHERWISE
THEY HAVE STAYED IN MY
POCKET FOR THE ENTIRE DAY.
SO LET’S FIND OUT WHAT THEY
KNOW.
THIS IS OUR MAN IN THE
MIDDLE DEVICE.
IT’S BASICALLY A WI-FI
NETWORK THAT THESE PHONES
ARE GOING TO CONNECT TO ONCE
WE TURN THEIR WI-FI ON.
IT’S GOING TO PASS DATA
THROUGH IT ON THE WAY TO
GOOGLE.
BUT ON THE WAY WE’RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET A COPY
OF THE SAME DATA THAT GOOGLE
IS GOING TO GET.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO DECRYPT
IT AND FIND OUT WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN THROUGHOUT THE
DAY.
WITHIN MINUTES THE NUMBERS
ROLLED IN, THE PHONE THAT
WASN’T ON AIRPLANE MODE
REGISTERED MORE THAN 100
LOCATIONS, 130 ACTIVITIES
AND EVEN 152 BAROMETRIC
READINGS.
AS SOON AS IT HOOKED UP TO
OUR WI-FI IT TRANSMITTED
300-KILO BITES OF DATA
STRAIGHT TO GOOGLE.
THE PHONE EVEN LOGGED OUR
EXACT LOCATIONS.
TRACKING US ALL AROUND TOWN.
THE CAPITOL, THE HOSPITAL,
THE SCHOOL, AND THE
CATHEDRAL.
>> NOW YOU MAY NOTICE WHAT’S
MISSING HERE IS THE EXACT
ROUTE THAT WE TOOK.
BUT IT GOT THAT DATA, TOO.
IT KNOWS WHEN I GOT OUT OF
THE CAR.
>> THE METADATA HAS A TIME
LOG DOWN TO THE VERY SECOND.
TRACKING EVERYTHING.
WHEN THEY THINK THAT YOU ARE
WALKING, RIDING, AND, YES,
EVEN GETTING OUT OF THE CAR.
>> OKAY.
SO YOU ARE THINKING THIS
ISN’T A WIG DEAL.
I WILL JUST PUT MY PHONE IN
AIRPLANE MODE.
YEAH, WE THOUGHT OF THAT,
TOO.
THIS IS THE OTHER PHONE THAT
WE HAD WITH US, NO SIM CARD,
ALSO REMAINS IN AIRPLANE
MODE THE ENTIRE TIME.
LET’S SEE WHAT KIND OF DATA
IT CAPTURED.
>> THE PHONE WITH AIRPLANE
MODE ACTIVATED ACTUALLY
LOGGED MORE LOCATIONS AND
ACTIVITIES THAN THE OTHER
PHONE.
AND IT ALSO TRANSFERRED
HUNDREDS OF KILO BITES OF
DATA TO GOOGLE AS SOON AS IT
WAS ACTIVATED.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT’S
MISSING FROM THIS MAP IS OUR
STOP AT THE CHOCHT.
BUT IT STILL KNOWS WE WERE
THERE.
THERE IT IS.
EXITING THE VEHICLE.
100 PERCENT ACCURACY.
>> THROUGH COMPLICATED USER
AGREEMENTS AND FREE SOFTWARE
GOOGLE GETS USERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR PRIVACY FOR
NOTHING.
THEY ARE EVEN FOLLOWING YOU
INTO PLACES THAT MOST PEOPLE
WOULD EXPECT TOTAL PRIVACY.
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS, A
CHILDREN’S HOSPITAL.
A PRIVATE SCHOOL.
A CHURCH.
EVERY MOVE YOU MAKE, EVERY
STEP YOU TAKE, GOOGLE IS
WATCHING YOU.
NOW, IN A STATEMENT TO FOX
NEWS, GOOGLE TOLD US THAT
USERS WHO WANT TO OPT OUT OF
TRACKING SHOULD TURN OFF
LOCATION HISTORY.
BUT DOING THAT IS HARDER
THAN YOU WOULD THINK AND
MOST OF GOOGLE’S APPS
INCLUDE HITTING QUERIES THAT
AUTOMATICALLY SIGN YOU UP
FOR THE SURVEILLANCE.
FOR NOW WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOKING INTO HOW SILICON
VALLEY SELLS YOUR PRIVACY.
JUST REMEMBER WHEN YOU ARE
USING A FREE ONLINE SERVICE,
YOU ARE PROBABLY NOT THE
CUSTOMER.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY THE
PRODUCT.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: SHOCKING.
AIRPLANE MODE ON, THEY ARE
STILL FOLLOWING EVERYTHING
YOU DO AND AUTOMATICALLY
UPDATES THEM.
I CAN’T WAIT TO FIND OUT